this is one of the most jaw-dropping
pieces of news media I've ever seen in
my life I mean it is it is incred anyone
that cares or has been following the
hunter Biden scandal the stuff with
barisma anyone over the last three to
four years watch this video watch it
from start to finish You're Gonna Want
More when it ends I don't know if they
they only got three and a half out of
her but I mean this is a tactic that can
be continued to you be used by the news
media until forbid they were supposed to
it's right they're supposed to ask about
these stories but it's but this is the
point I was bringing up in the in the in
the debate show I'm like how about if
you don't know whether or not Joe Biden
did or did not engage in a quid pro quo
you just say yeah I don't know enough
about that but I don't like Biden so I'm
not going to give him the benefit of the
doubt how about you just say I'm not
gonna comment for some reason there's
this adamant need among these left
personalities like I'm not talking about
liberals either like leftists will be
like I don't like Joe Biden I won't
defend him but this story is not true
and I'm like you don't know anything
about the story why are you defending
him